no heroic saga is complete without a
villain the MCU has suffered no lack of
buddies thus far and face for plumber
sister continue that trend today we're
taking a look at every new villain
coming our way and phase four of the MCU
one of the few phase 4 villains who've
gotten a decent glimpse of as black
widows taskmaster aka Anthony masters
that's a boy masters discovered that he
could replicate any physical action once
he has observed it empowered by these
photographic reflexes taskmaster turns
to a life of crime and becomes extremely
wealthy looking to expand his reach he
opens a school where he shapes other
villains and to lean mean good guy
busting machines since he's able to
replicate the fighting style of any hero
he provides his pupils with uniquely
individualized training taskmasters
abilities prove enormous lead Ange Russ
in the heat of battle as he can predict
his foes next moves and stays several
steps ahead
he should prove for an interesting fofo
natasha in black widow given her own
skills of subterfuge adaptation
admittedly fans have sort of encountered
the Mandarin already Marvel pulled the
rug out from underneath us in Iron Man 3
by portraying Ben Kingsley as a classic
villain only to reveal him as an actor
named Trevor Slattery he was only ever
hired to portray a made-up supervillain
that wasn't the end for the Mandarin
however fans will be getting the real
deal in shang-chi and The Legend of the
ten rings with Tony lei yung shell was
set to portray the actual no falling
Mandarin the Mandarin is both
intellectually and physically formidable
but the biggest threat he poses comes
from the ten rings he was crafted from
the remains of a crashed alien spaceship
each ring grants him a different ability
how's Shang she will handle such a
formidable threat remains to be seen but
is certain to be in a miserable showdown
eternals was a bit of a surprise
announcement they're not exactly a
high-profile super team then again a
guardians of the galaxy was a massive
success and I am man used to be a
seedless hero before becoming the MC use
poster boy why shouldn't a race of
immortal cosmic beings of fabulous taste
in leotards become Marvel's next big
thing
he will Menace the titular Eternals the
deviants genetic offshoots of the
Eternals they were driven into hiding
after an attempted rebellion against the
Celestials the godlike alien creatures
of both groups we're not yet sure which
specific characters will be felons in
eternals many deviants have come and
gone over the years regardless of who
ends up in the
film though we're sure to be in for a
wild ride doctor strain to the
multiverse of madness will allegedly
take the MCU into the realm of horror
all signs point to one of the central
villains of the film being nightmare a
powerful demon who has been one of dr.
Strange's most prominent foes for
decades my mare is extraordinarily
powerful he controls a terrifying part
of the dream dimension called the
nightmare world where he feeds off human
psychic energy he can completely
incapacitated for heroes and even use
his influence to dominate and control
others while only would he be a
formidable foe for Doctor Strange it's
easy to imagine him stepping into an
ongoing antagonist role similar to Loki
we know that drew egg will be part of
the Eternals and that Barry qyn is
stepping into the role we also know that
druid would likely be a villain and he
is one of the group's classic foes
however we're still calling it a rumor
because we know so little about the
Eternals at this time if Jarek does wind
up being a villain he would be a
formidable one drew egg it's not
actually a deviant but an eternal
long-lived an enormous leap powerful his
abilities are fast and varied
telekinesis flights telepathy matter
transformation and illusion are all
within his wheelhouse on top of that he
is a ruthless highly intelligent schema
and the ruler of an entire country in
the comics the MCU will be expanding to
include Disney plus television shows and
phase 4 and the first show to see
release will be the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier
we know that Zima will be a central
villain of the series but he might not
be alone John Walker aka u.s. agents
might just join him
Walker was created in the 1980s to serve
as a dark reflection of Captain
America's idealism where Captain America
personifies all the positive traits of
being American u.s. agent as patriotism
taken to ugly violent extremes of
nationalism as xenophobia and
callousness though Walker has changed
his ways over the years ending up a good
guy he certainly didn't debut that way
and seems likely to service one of the
Falcon and the winter soldiers
electrifying villains Thor love and
thunder is now slated for a February
2022 release standing in Thor's way will
be someone we don't yet know the
character but we do know the villain
will be played by Christian Bale most of
the evidence indicates that Bale will
plague or the god butcher gore is an
alien from an impoverished planet after
losing his loved ones he arrives at the
conclusion that there are no gods he is
shocked then to discover that gods are
entire
real they just did nothing as he and his
family starved from that day on he makes
it his goal to destroy as many guns as
he can find God would be a great favor
Thor his weapon or black the necro sword
is arguably more powerful than me Oh Nia
and his backstory is enormous ly
compelling in an era of the MCU bursting
with eternal sorceress supreme and
Asgardian gods
throwing a non-believer like gore into
the mix could make for an incredible
movie the Loki Disney Plus series will
most likely follow the rogue timeline
Loki created by stealing the tesseract
in Avengers and game however some small
details hint a to Loki will be up
against in that series the time variance
Authority the TVA is essentially a group
of time-traveling police who seek to
stop those who would screw up the
multiverses timeline the Loki spot
revealed during the Superbowl showed
Loki as a prisoner of the TVA
so we know they'll at least be a part of
the series this brings us to Owen Wilson
Wilson has been cast as an unknown role
in Loki and the rumor mill has pegged
him as Justice piece though peace takes
himself very seriously he is often
played for laughs
Wilson's comedic experience paired with
Hiddleston's charm could work perfectly
staying in water until I get the call
from the mothership I resumed at that
then I fight check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite MCU movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]